You are, you're painting a fantasy.
You see it as a fantasy. I mean,
I think the fantasy is using the system
to think that it's going to bend to our
will.
Okay.
Uh, my name is Derek Bros. I'm
33 I'm from Houston, Texas.
I'm a journalist and an activist.
My name is Kaitlin.
I'm originally from the bay area,
but I just,
we were down and I am 21 years old.
I'm Andrew. I am 27 years old. I'm from
Scandia, Minnesota and I'm a documentary
filmmaker.
I am Telisa Ray on 42 and I'm
a senior analyst for a utility.
My name is [inaudible].
I'm 21 and I am a student.
My name is Renada.
I'm 24 I'm from Pennsylvania and
I worked for a software company.
Can I give my folders on the left side?
And mine is on the right side.
Bye.
Okay.
Well,
I believe my vote matters because I'm a
woman and first it was denied for us and
now I have the opportunity to
use my voice. But in addition,
I'm able to use my voice as a black woman.
Excuse me.
I get a little emotional about that.
Considering though we were citizens
black people long time ago,
we weren't given really the right or we
were denied x accessibility to go to the
voting polls until I feel like it is
my opportunity to go ahead and speak.
I have the ability to vote,
I have the privilege of civil so
I will do so and like growing up,
like my,
my oldest sister wasn't able to vote
until like a couple of years ago because
he's autistic and since it's the whole
guardianship thing and it was actually
until a couple of years ago that people
under guardianship were able to vote.
And also because of the undocumented
people that are around me and my family,
all the formerly incarcerated people
that are disproportionately affecting,
you know, black people. I think
it's always important to vote,
not for myself but for them.
I come from Minnesota and I think
it's a very civically involved state.
I always saw it,
everybody you kind of voted.
And when I was going into college,
I was a part of this campaign
called the vote no campaign,
which was to turn down a
constitutional amendment,
which would have made it illegal for
gay people to get married and I am gay.
And so I got involved in that campaign
too to try to prevent it from happening.
And we went from a very low approval rate,
um,
same sex marriage in Minnesota too,
in just less than a year, um, uh,
very large approval rate.
And we ended up to feeding
that constitutional amendment
and eventually became
one of the states that
legalized same sex marriage.
I'm part seminars as well.
And our ancestry is same thing,
had been denied different.
Uh,
I hesitate to call them rights because
I don't think things that the government
gives you our rights. I'm like
privileges, you know? So I,
I don't really know if
I would call it that,
but I definitely understand them denying
a certain privileges in the past and
how now that we have those privileges,
sometimes we feel inclined to like, well,
my ancestors didn't get to do this,
so I need to do this,
but I still hesitate to say that my vote
matters. Now there are some instances,
like for example,
you were talking about gay marriage and
I think maybe on a local level we could
see the impact of our actions.
I think it's become increasingly clear
that whether you're talking about the
electoral college or voting
machines being hacked or you know,
we're not even getting into
philosophical side of things,
that your vote really doesn't matter
that the end of the day there's a small
group of people who decide what goes,
yeah,
I can understand your point, especially
with the history part. However,
I also feel though that it's an informed
decision that I'm making and of course
it's more impactful locally.
And because of that,
because of my community and where I
live and all the changes that occur,
it's important for me to,
to have that voice even if there's an
off chance that it may not really be
effective. It's my right to use that voice
and I'm sure you can understand that.
I think my vote does matter to an extent
where it shows that I agree what's
happening politically and since I do
disagree with what's going on politically
and I don't believe that this country has
a true democracy. That's where I think,
um, my vote doesn't matter
at that point. For me,
I'm more of a moderate,
but I do lean a little bit conservative.
But as Finn from being in California,
you know the votes are going to be
towards more democratic votes. Personally,
I don't think my vote wouldn't matter.
You know, when I'm voting for the primary,
the way I see it is that I vote every
single day. I vote with my actions.
I'm very involved in my community.
Well it drives me crazy.
I guess it's just that every two to four
years people all of a sudden pop up and
act like they know what's going on around
the country just because the TV or the
Internet is telling them, oh, it's
that time to pay attention again.
And so they get ready to,
you know,
and then you get to the point where some
people are shaming those who choose not
to participate, you know? So, uh, you
know, I just, I guess just for me,
I want to encourage more people to vote
with their very being, not just like,
right on that list of a paper or press
that button and like, okay, that's it.
I'll worry about it again in
two years, four years, whatever.
Okay.
Yeah.
I mean, I'm proud to be
American. I really am.
There's a lot of opportunities
that this country has given me. Um,
I don't necessarily agree what's
happening in the government.
I don't necessarily agree
with the way of life here,
but I'm happy to be from here
and I'll always be proud of.
I had moved to Brazil to finish my
degree and when I was living there,
I kind of had to make the decision whether
I wanted to move back to the United
States are not.
The reason why I was thinking about
staying in Brazil was why I wasn't happy
with some of the things going on
in the United States, the politics,
the healthcare system,
all of these things were just
stacking up and I was thinking, God,
that country is going to
shit. But I realized, well,
I can either be a part of the solution
and making it better or I can just give
up and run away.
But I chose to come back here and I've
been living here for five years now
though I am glad to be here in America.
When I think of patriotic,
I think of,
I believe in everything
that the country stands for.
You know how we operate and I'm just
going to be honest with you. I don't, um,
it's too many injustices
in today's society.
I'm a bit embarrassed
to say I'm an American.
The whole lesser of two evils.
That's exactly why does it have to be
to me both. Yeah, exactly. Why not?
Why can't evil. Yeah. Or why not
look to other parties, party systems.
I don't fall under any of that under my,
my religion,
not one politician has ever understood
what it's like to be a Muslim.
Nothing is being, nothing's being
pushed on my agenda and it won't be.
It will not be. Um, and I think the
whole system, the way it's set up,
it's just,
it's always has an agenda first certain
type of people and it's always going to
be for that certain type of people.
It's a propaganda to get people,
the masses of people to believe that we
have a voice and to believe that we have
democracy when we really do.
Do you not,
I don't want to agree with the voice
part, but everything else. But you didn't,
you don't agree that they were the
right candidates? I don't know.
I don't have a voice side
where this country's going.
The way I understand it works though is
they got there somehow they got there
through, so we're kind of out. But they
did. They cheated their way there. I mean,
even when somebody like Bernie
Sanders tried to say, hey,
we're gonna use all our grass roots
delegates and we're gonna challenge this
system using their own rules
and they just change the rules.
I guess that's why I feel
like we should vote though.
Especially right now for the primaries,
it's like,
I don't think we should give up.
It sounds like you guys,
no, not at all. Not at all. Not Giving up.
It's just approaching it in a different
way to me. I was going to say though,
as an activist,
aren't you trying to promote change
through your actions but through people's
minds? Not to the political
system? Well, for me,
I didn't vote for either two candidates.
I wanted one Jen,
John Casick to when the Republican
Party, but he didn't. Um,
and then also Gary Johnson
as an independent, uh,
personally I didn't want
to vote independent because
just my community members
seeing on social media don't
vote independent or are you
going to lead Trump win?
I can't please both sides cause it's so
far left or far right. And I'm just like,
what do I do? You know? And, um,
I think I got to the point where I
got frustrated where it's just like,
you know what?
I'm just not going to vote.
I just feel that our current system is
not inclusive of everyone's thoughts and
ideas.
Yeah. Like when we create a binary, um,
we've forced people to choose
one thing or the other.
And that exists like in all
aspects of, um, you know,
being a person and participating
and you know, politics,
like there's so many
different types of people.
There's so many like different types of,
you know,
thoughts that they have
that could be beneficial.
And I think we should probably
start existing outside of that.
Shane.
Yeah. I think it's the bottom is us as
individual since a, we're considered,
you know, the bottom, the last resort
that, that voice that's, you know,
small. I think that we're the bottom
and so we start with the change.
Change starts with us when we look in
the mirror and how we see ourselves and
how we see other people.
I believe that's where it starts.
Absolutely. You know, I
think that really the,
the smallest minority we talked
about a lot is from minorities,
but the smallest minority that is
always under threat is the individual.
You know, those individuals can be
gay, can be black, if you're white,
can be Muslim,
but it's the individual individual rights
pertaining to a number of different
issues. At the end of the
day. I think that, you know,
Minnesota would got a lot sooner to gay
marriage and approval of that if the
government just got the heck out of the
way and let free people do whatever they
want and get married as
they please and you know,
vote when they please and you know,
come just get the heck out of the way
and all sorts of arenas and let people
organize their affairs. You know, men,
women, whatever color, whatever religion.
I get that, but that's not an
option. I think like you're, you,
you're painting a fantasy on,
you see it as a fantasy. I mean,
I think the fantasy is using the system
to think that it's going to bend to our
will. I mean that that wasn't
an option. That's not a choice.
It's like you could say the
same thing about women's rights,
African American rights
and I believe in it,
but people worked together to change that.
And that's what I'm saying.
I think that's where the divide is,
is like right now I'm saying we should
work together to have a positive impact
on the future. I'm with you. I just
won't follow you into the ballot.
Okay.
Consider the system that we are in today
and how you can make the change today.
Whether you feel that it is not impactful,
your vote for me matters.
Your vote locally matters.
It'll change something in someone's
community. Um, so consider for me,
I want you to consider the thought that
someone else somewhere else does not
have the same opportunity to go in and
be heard in the way that they choose.
Let me,
I'm always going to have a lot of
respect for people who decide not to vote
because they don't
believe this system works.
I agree to that to a certain extent.
But I believe that local wording
is always the most important thing.
And like voting in community has always
been a part of forming that community.
I think for now on it's just more like I
hope that there are people who won't be
too far right to far left and that we
could all just kind of like chill out and
that I could like, you
know, just vote because it,
it's my opinion and my ideas and that I
hope that no one belittles me for that
opinion that I might have.
It might not be popular or it might not
be trending on social media but that it
will be just accepted and
that I don't need it to sweat.
Like take one side or the other side.
At the end of the day.
People can do whatever they want and
they can keep it private to themselves as
well. And if you continue doing
the same things that you're doing,
nothing's going to change.
All right.
I'm so sorry.
Hey guys,
Jason from jubilee here.
Thank you so much for watching another
episode of middle ground. As always,
we love hearing from you guys and we'd
love to hear thoughts in the comments
below. Let us know if there's some name
that you disagreed with or agreed with.
We love seeing that discussion and and
creating this radical empathy. As always,
make sure you click to subscribe
to more videos from jubilee extra.
Hit the bell for notifications.
Click here to watch more videos and
we'll see you next time. Live grader.